Okay.
Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the
Monday morning podcast from Monday,
January 18th, 2016.
How's it going out? Uh,
I am recording this
Sunday afternoon and uh,
in Vancouver, uh, Canada
doing two shows here tonight.
It's halftime. Actually third quarter
just started off the Bronco Steelers.
I missed a Seattle and a Carolina.
I know that must've been a great
fucking game. It kills me. You know,
you never know when you book the fucking
gigs that have game like that is going
to be on. But uh, I
imagined that that was, uh,
as good as the score looked. And of
course I'm up here in Canada and uh,
I don't know. They don't have,
they just went to boomer and all those
guys at halftime time and all they did
was interview Cam Newton.
They asked him one question,
you know how he didn't answer,
you know, he just talked,
didn't give an answer about anything.
They like, what do they get? Did the a,
the second half to a, you know, uh,
blah, blah, blah, blah. And he just goes,
yeah, well, you know,
our offense and our defense and of
course the special teams, you know,
everybody's got a job to do and a,
they get out there and they, uh,
try to get done enough.
Fortunately today we were able to get
out there and execute some of the things
we'll be working with all
this weekend. Uh, you know,
next week we got another person
that we're going to be playing.
I should set a team, not a person to
be on the team. We're going to play.
I know. We just hope that a, you know,
we're just gonna try to keep
it going because uh, you know,
we're all trying to win
a championship here.
Yeah.
And by the end you're just like, I did,
what the fuck did I even ask you? Um,
I wonder if, you know, cause athletes,
anything they fucking say they going to
take it out of context. So they just,
they get trained to just answer and not
say anything. Just like a politician.
I want. If you could fucking
turn that off. You know,
if you stay in the league long enough,
if you drive your wife nuts, you know,
Holly, do you know where my shows
are? Well, you know, you're to,
you own a lot of stuff and sometimes
that stuff gets misplaced at a,
you can do is just try to fire on all
cylinders and try to find the things that
you can have and a, if you can find them,
you can find them. And if you can't a,
then you've got to move onto the next
thing. But, uh, you know, it was always,
I'm always looking
towards the next weekend.
Another thing that's going
to be lost and lost. So I,
we're definitely going to do everything
we can to find it. Uh, the offense,
defense and special
teams, no, not healthy.
Um, anyways. Uh, yeah. So
I'm up here in Vancouver.
God Damn it. It's fucking beautiful
up here. Fucking gorgeous man.
Especially when you live in,
you know where the hell I live,
which was not designed to have really
anybody living there other than I guess
maybe some indigenous people
sending smoke signals, you know,
probably sending smoke
signals that, you know,
can you find any food cause we can't.
I'm sick of eating snake and do you
want to get the fuck Outta here?
How would the fuck you do that
with smoke signals? It must,
must've been pretty
God damn simple. Right?
The smoke signals if they even did it
or is that just another Hollywood thing
that they threw a blunt? I mean,
how do you even fucking do that?
I guess she had to go, obviously
you got to put the fire out, right?
Oh, what do I, how the fuck would
you do that? You know? All right,
one big puff of fuck. It's, you
gotta know what kind of wood to burn.
What a pain in the ass.
Jesus Christ. I'm going to get lost in.
Remember getting lost at the
mall before a fucking cell phone.
That was unbelievable. Forget about back
then. If you get lost, you are fucked.
Okay.
Hey, anybody see a, what the
fuck was that guy's name?
Okay.
Oh, fucking red face. Where did he go?
Done. I mean, how long do you look?
You can't really yell. You're
going to attract wild animals.
Cool.
Just walking around the woods. Hey Eddy,
eddy the fuck are you.
This isn't funny man. Um,
anyways, but you come up here
after leaving the desert. Um,
what am I see at the say the desert?
I always think of a that awesome.
Great Greg Giraldo. Rest his soul joke
where he did that whole thing about, uh,
how eloquent the words, that
words the notes were that, uh,
soldiers wrote during
the civil war, you know,
versus some of the letters from
people coming back from re Iraq.
Uh, what am I, I came
about with fucking wet.
It's really hard to be out here with the
ball sticking g like out here in the,
in the desert. You,
I remember the difference between
desert and desert to us is for dessert.
More calories. Right? There
you go. That's how I do it.
And don't even ask me to spell restaurant
cause I won't even fucking remember.
So anyways, I'm up here in Vancouver,
so we go to fucking land, um, and just,
Oh my God, all the lush greenery,
all the lakes, although water,
everything we don't have
down in La, beautiful houses,
I guess it's expensive as shit up
here. And they was saying how, um,
a lot of Asian people,
um,
you know, not indigenous
foreigners, you know,
they got to get rid of
their fucking money.
They get to wash their money or I don't
what the fuck it is that government's
going to take it all. So they, uh,
use this place up here like a Swiss
bank and they buy like super expensive
places for cash,
um,
which drives the housing market
up. It's fucking nuts, man.
Anytime you go to another country,
you just hear the shit that they
fucking dealing with. I just, you know,
you always think like you'd come up here,
Canada is going to have no
fucking problems. You know,
you watch one Michael Moore documentary
that just gives you a complete,
like misinterpretation of what
the fuck is going on up here.
So they, I guess they had
to make some sort of law.
Um,
that you couldn't do something like that.
I can't make him what the fucking
person told him when all the weed,
while the way to the
fucking supreme court,
there was like a group of people from
Asia that was so rich that they actually
sued an entire country for not letting
them either come into the country or,
uh,
by a bunch of shit over here that drove
the housing market stuff up or something
that, or by their citizenship.
I can't even fucking remember.
But that's the charm of this podcast.
You know, I get a little information,
I barely remember half of it and I
just fucking run with it. That's all.
Um, so anyways, um,
so it went all the way to the Supreme
Court and then they were just finally
like, ah, yeah,
you kind of have to be from this
country for us to give a fuck about you,
you know, to like win a
lawsuit. So, uh, see you later.
And that's, it ended, I guess the
lawyer for them knew the whole way,
going all the way up that it
wasn't going to happen. You know,
they weren't going to win it
and he just took their money.
He probably had to sit
there and work on his, uh,
I'm disappointed we lost
two phase, you know,
as he took all their
fucking money. But anyways,
so let's talk about NFL football. What
[inaudible] um, the fucking patriots.
They one, God dammit. Thank
Christ they won. They Christ,
they one in Seattle, Los
Thank Christ. You know,
if we're going to keep advancing, I just
didn't want Seattle to get the revenge.
You can't remember forever
if I've already said this,
I just didn't want to see Seattle get
the revenge on a banged up Patriot team.
If we come in healthy and they kick
our ass good on them. But uh, you know,
congratulations to the
Carolina Panthers. Uh,
they gotta be the favorites at this
point. Come on. They 16 and fucking one.
Right. Got that young defense
than at scared of Shit.
They just beat Seattle.
Right. Who knows? But, um,
I don't know shit about football.
I've, I've just been so fucking busy,
so I'm still going to talk about it.
You guys can keep trashing me that I
don't know. Shit, I don't give a fuck. Um,
and by the way,
this is why I never record on a day that
I flew cause my brain is even more all
over the place than it usually is,
especially when I got a fucking TV
going on in the background. But uh,
you know, I got, I got a busy
fucking datum. I fly back tomorrow,
get a busy fucking day. So I apologize
if this is all over the place,
even more than usual. I as
a first down for this damn
fucking 25. Oh, somebody else up here.
It gives a shit about NFL football.
I know they have CFL ends in like,
is it the end of November?
They have the Grey Cup,
which is their super bowl or
is it a December? I don't know.
The people even give a shit.
You ever see the fucking stadiums
for their football teams up here?
It's like you sit in the
stands, you can see your car,
you know one of those deals
where there's like a fucking,
you watch them kick a field
goal and you're looking at
traffic driving by on the
street.
Like those old school football stadiums
from like the 60s and seventies you
know, where they would have like
the horseshoe shaped stadium,
which was I think what happened with what
with football stadiums was when there
wasn't that many people in the
or, and also the leaks were small.
They just had people sitting
on both sides, right?
You had the home side and the
visitors side and that was it.
And then as there's more and more
people population got bigger,
the leagues got bigger than they built
end zone seats that connected both sides.
I think they just did it on one side
first. Then you had the horseshoe, right?
Like the fucking a Broncos
plated, the Buckeyes,
a Buckeye still call it the horse.
They still call it a horseshoe even
though they fucking closed in it.
And then eventually there was people,
people did so much fucking that
they had the clothes, you know.
And there's so much ESPN
that got everybody fucking
interested in it that isn't
even interested in it. Then
all of a sudden Beyonce
singing at fucking halftime,
you know? And there's a bunch of people
in the crowd that are excited by it.
Yeah. Um,
a fucking old ass Rod Stewart.
Who the fuck they dragon out?
They always usually go with somebody
young or they just fucking drag somebody
who out, who's on their last fucking legs,
like their last big payday, you know,
they just fucking wheel them out
there. They going to do this year?
Huh? Night Ranger. Do you think going
to be like night ranger? A Drake?
That's what I'm guessing. I'll wait.
I think it is Beyonce. You know?
I know because Nia wanted to go to the
Superbowl because Beyonce was there.
I'm like, why don't you
go see her in concert?
You're going to make us go to the fucking
super bowl and then we get to watch
your lip sync. One fucking song. How the
fuck did Sean Penn interview that drug,
Lord, how do you do something like that?
And the government isn't like, Hey, you
know, we're trying to find that guy.
You know when you're just sitting
there palling around with them.
Probably bought them like fast
times at Ridgemont high DVDs. Right.
For his underground layer.
Yeah.
Dude, I love shod pen as an actor.
But how out of your fucking tree are you
that you're going to go and
interview that fucking guy?
Okay.
You know I did that.
I'm trying to think how many fucking
standup specials I would have to put out
before I could go. I would go fucking
interview somebody and like I the,
well I guess Isis is actually fight, but
we're fucking with them too. You know?
I would just think I'm going to
walk in there with my microphone.
They're all going to laugh at me. Then
they're going to saw my fucking head off.
Or were you gonna Worse? Tie me to a
chair. Fucking torture me to death.
That's insane. Hey, good on
him also. I don't understand.
Is it El Chapo? That's his name. He
sounds like such a gentleman. Huh?
El Is a good chap. El Chapo.
MMM. [inaudible]
I don't fucking get it, man.
What are you doing?
Why, why did he go down
there and interview that guy?
Okay.
And like how, how,
wow.
How well does Sean movies do that?
Drug dealers on the run. He's on
the run from our government, right?
Isn't this the guy who
escaped? I don't fucking know.
You know what's going on is my fucking
Internet won't let me sign on so I can't
fucking see anything. I can't see
the fucking highlights. Nothing.
You know,
while I'm up here is I fucking got one
God damn channel and a bunch of Tim
Horton fucking commercials,
which is at Dunkin donuts.
See if I can sign on here is an El Chapo.
The guy that liked that we would,
that keeps escaping from
jail. Set the Guy El Chapo.
Come on man. Come on. Ah,
this connection is untrusted.
Yeah. Jesus Christ.
It's probably some psycho from
Alberta trying to hack in here.
That seems like their Texas
to me, when you're up here,
it's all fucking oil man
and ranchers and shit. Um,
and then you've got Edmonton,
Edmonton. Seems like it's nice.
You know what I mean? Like that's
their like business hub. You know,
I'm just totally judging
these just by doing,
like driving through and doing a
little bit of standup out here.
Like when I did stand up in Calgary,
great people, but fucking animals,
Jesus fucking Christ.
They weren't animals.
I don't know if it's cause the place
that we performed at there was like no
carpeting or nothing. They were fucking,
I think it was Casa cause
it was bring your own beer.
Fucking animals.
I would never fuck with
anybody from Calgary.
Yeah.
I saw the way they behave when they were
in a good mood. Ex excited for a show.
Don't have a fuck with
anybody from Calgary.
What's Edmonton? It was
civilized. Calgary. Jesus Christ.
They had everything but a hookers
swinging from a swing. You know,
back in the old days with the salons
where they had the horse, you know,
way over dressed. Once again, it might
just be a fucking movie thing. So much.
So much of my history is
based on it. By the way,
I can't get on the fucking Internet,
but for some reason I could fucking, uh,
I could do it over the, uh,
I could do it on my phone.
Let me look up El Chapo here. I
said he sounds like such a chap.
I just think like that English
think, Eh. Well, Chapo,
he's a Mexican chap.
How Mexico secretly launched a
crackdown after Penn met El Chapo.
How El Chapo was finally captured
again. That was one day ago.
We'll el Chapo rat out rival
cartels. Corrupt officials.
It's gotta be a lot of stress.
Be In this El Chapo guy. Huh?
Joaquin Guzman.
Yeah.
You know, I got to say,
he looks like a Mexican Robert Blake like
during the Beretta years that when he
says a, yeah, that's me who's also on
the phone and then starts laughing.
How else this is when, you know,
you lived a fucking crazy life.
This is just the front page of this guys
for a, if you search this guy's name,
how El Chapo was finally captured again,
will el Chapo rally red? Those, uh,
El Chapo Guzman. Sean
Penn talks about them.
El Chapo had erectile dysfunction
surgery while on the run.
That's nice to know. We took a pit stop.
You know, guy takes care of himself.
How nervous was that doctor
working on that maniacs? Dick? Uh,
El Chapo speaks rolling stone.
Sean Penn has terrible regret
about meeting El Chapo. Well,
what did he think he was going to meet?
Okay,
he's going to get some fucking Sherry's
berries. The hunt for El Chapo,
Joaquin El Chapo Guzman. The
truth about the jailbreak,
there's nothing here about a, an older,
wiser El Chapo puts out a little singer
Songwriter Jesus fucking Christ. Dude,
you don't realize how fucking finished
we are. Just as, as, as, as, uh,
just as a race, as a race, as
humanity. So I'm trying to say,
just as people were fucking
done, you know, rolling stone.
Rolling stone this month has
Sean Penn talking to El Chapo,
the Leonardo DiCaprio's on the con cover,
and they're billing Billingham where
he has a plan to save the planet.
Okay.
Why are we doing,
what the fuck is that government
not doing that a list fucking a
actress have to talk to drug
lords and try to save the planet.
I mean, there's gotta be how many leaks
are in the fucking dam at this point?
I don't know about you guys. That
does not make me feel comfortable.
You don't have any boomer Esiason to
figure out how to Co
fucking colonize Mars.
That's the next thing that they're gonna
have in the rolling. Rolling Stone.
You don't have a why? What the
fuck do I want to hear that?
Okay.
Can I hear a scientist?
You know,
how about I have a navy
seal interview. El Chapo.
Okay.
I don't know bill, how would you
shut the fuck up? All right, I will.
I don't know. I get unsettled.
I get unsettled him. I did.
I have problems with digestion. Um,
I can't even remember what the
fuck I was going to look up.
What was I initially looking
at before I got to El Chapo?
Jesus Christ. Some of
the stories on that guy.
Yeah.
You know,
it's right up there with that fucking Raj
Stewart rumor for way back in the day.
If I that one, I think it was, I can't
remember. I've still, whatever they're,
yeah, they found like a gallon
of [inaudible] in his stomach.
His stomach had to be
pumped, you know, a gallon.
You went to trader Joe's and butts them
up. Fucking all natural organic. Fuck,
I'm sorry. Um, you got a gallon of
it, you know? No, you went to a,
was those foods, that place where you
buy everything in Bulk? Let's fuck it.
Whales. It, push it around those
pallet jacks by and cheerios.
Okay.
You got to get a membership to it
because with a C it's not [inaudible].
What's the, what's the name of that?
I never go to the fucking place.
Once I had to go in there
and get a membership,
they wanted all this fucking information.
Um,
oh Christ, what the fuck is
it called? That coat check.
I'm never going to remember
it. You know what I'm saying?
That just kills the jokes. But when you
can't remember the fucking references,
it just, it absolutely kills it. Costco.
Hey went to Costco.
He bought one of those big fucking a
gallons a fucking ges it on a dairy,
chugged it. Anyway, so there's, he
has something on El Chapo, El Chapo.
They said a,
okay.
I can't remember like just fucking killed
this person's whole family took their
kids and something. I
just, I don't believe it.
They took his kids and
then flew him to uh,
to Columbia and then threw him
off a bridge. It's like, really?
There's not any bridges in Mexico.
You never know what to believe.
But I gotta tell you when
you go south or the US,
you do not want to piss anybody
off as far as I can tell.
That's some next level shit.
And I could say that because I just
read papers from the United States.
They uh, that's just,
that's just next level.
Like you know,
you mad at somebody and then you know how
you get your revenge is just some next
, I read that a killing Pablo.
One time I had to put the
book down like three times.
Some of the shit they just
said that the guy did not,
I don't know if the
fucking guy did this shit,
but I'm a one time hearing that the guy
had a party night and everybody's out
there by the pool standing around, you
know, and a, what's his face there?
Pablo Escobar standing there. You know,
everybody's ignoring the weight that
he's putting on as he sits there and his
fucking Hager action slacks, you know,
seemed to like those is stretched and uh,
yeah,
you know, still tucked them in right
at the waist, you know what I mean?
Talk to him right in the waist.
Didn't push the pants down,
didn't do the fucking share it on,
tucked. He tucked it right in. And uh,
they said that he, he
allegedly filed one of his, uh,
one of the people didn't want to,
it's not as by one of the maids.
I don't know what allegedly was stealing.
So they tied this guy's legs together
and his arms behind the his back and they
threw him in the house pool and just
watched him drown as everyone was standing
there at the party. You know,
I'd say they must've been a lot of ice
shaken and drinks after that one. Like
so is this a Victorian house? Pablo?
Mr Escobar. Oh, I want
to go the pool. Um, yeah.
People get their faces ripped
off. Is it torturing to death?
They're like peeling their fucking
faces back. This is not funny.
This is not what this
podcast is about. Um,
why is this fucking Steeler
Denver Games so fucking boring?
Is it because I have the sound
down? I just don't give a fuck.
The AFC is just the
walking wounded, right?
This burger is a fucking man.
Look at a guy just getting bumped by
Lyme and he stays in there. That guy,
he has like fucking, he stays
in the pocket like Steve Grogan.
Stuff used to stay in the pocket.
Did anybody remember that?
Any old pats fans out there?
You'd fucking sit there.
And this is back when you could literally,
you could hammer a fucking quarterback,
drive your helmet right under his chin
and then lift him off the ground and
pile, drive them into
the fucking astroturf,
which is like getting tackled in
a parking lot. That's been, uh,
painted green and Steve Drogan,
whenever he would go back for a pass,
it's back when he had that fucking
neck brace and he had such a long neck,
he could still see like six inches in
neck. Right. Even with the neck brace.
And there'd be some defensive lineman
just run in full speed right at him.
And he, he would just hang onto
it, hang onto and hang on to it,
and then he would throw the ball and
the camera would follow the football.
And right as he let it go,
you'd see just the beginning of that
fucking Lyman drilling them and he'd go
flying right out the right side
of your screen or left side,
depending on which way he was going
down the field to Stanley Morgan,
you know, Russ Francis, one
of those fucking guys, right?
Harold Jackson. Who else
did we have back then?
I can't even fucking remember.
Hasselbeck they had Hasselbeck
whose son was the one who said, uh,
we want the ball and we're going to
score don Hasselbeck I think was,
is dead. All right. Anyways, where
the, where the fuck am I? Um,
yeah. Rothberg is like that,
that guy stands in the pocket and takes
a fuck at it and speak in which to, uh,
I know there's a lot of Kansas City fans
would probably pissed off at the calls
Tom Brady got and the lack of
calls that Alex Smith got. Ed. Uh,
I'm a patriots fan. Uh,
you're absolutely right,
but that is not Tom Brady's fault. Okay.
And I'm hoping most of you guys have kids.
The city can hear what I'm saying because
you're not as upset because you got to
see your baseball team when
the world series. Right?
So you got that going for you.
Half of you professional teams
won championships this year.
That's pretty fucking good. Right? Um,
Tom Brady earned those
costs. Okay. This is the,
if you want Alex Smith to get
those calls in the future,
in the future,
he has to make the NFL owners
a lot more money than he is.
And that's just a simple fact. And people
call it the Tom Brady rules. It isn't,
it's the superstar rules. You know,
Jordan gets away with the push.
Right? What was the last
time we, Colby Bryant.
What does Colby Bryan have
to do to get, you know, well,
he's not healthy anymore,
but back in the day you could be standing
in the lane before the fucking game
starts and if he runs it to you that
they're going to call it on you,
he'd literally have to,
to eat after fucking tie an ax to the
front of knee and fucking jump into your,
cut your head off before, you know,
if there was a way to call offsetting,
they would have, it's just,
it's just how it works. But, um,
I have to say as much
as he earned the calls,
that one where he was getting sacked
and he switched it to his left hand and
throw it and they still gave him
the call was fucking ridiculous.
I even as a pager, it's fair. I was
at home going, oh, what the fuck?
Give me a break. But
you know, I'll take it.
Of course they'll take it the same
way you would have. Um, but, uh,
I don't care to see. It's a great team
and they have, you know, Alex Smith,
I think he's going to be a really
fucking great quarterback. Um,
but you gotta have it all man.
He gotta have the coach and the ownership
and all that bullshit and lucky enough
that we have that in, uh, in
New England. So there you go.
That's me trying to not be a cunt.
All right. And uh,
Oh God, I can't wait to go home and
watch that fucking Carolina Panther game,
man.
I think you're going to see like all
these people that they were saying or the
heir apparent to fucking Tom
Brady and Peyton manning.
I think it's a,
okay.
I think it's, what's his
face there? The panthers,
I can't remember his fucking name. What
is wrong with me? He went to Auburn,
right? He does the superman
thing. Cam Newton. Here we go.
Um,
anyways, that'll let you guys know this.
I'm supposed to read this shit here,
but of course I get up, type in my
fucking password, which takes forever.
I'm on for fuck sakes.
I got to have a fucking 20 letter password
and numbers cause God knows everybody
wants to break into my computer and
read my Dick Jokes here. Um, oh,
Andrew asked you guys, he said,
please ask the listeners to put relevant
subject lines in their emails if they
want them. Red Putting Hay doesn't
help with a thousand thousands a week,
trying not to miss any of
the good ones. Thanks. Um,
I probably could have nice
and that up a little bit.
He sorta texted me that really
quickly. Um, yeah, so if you guys have,
it's a subject, whatever, uh,
you know, anything, you know.
Okay.
Fuck Tom Brady, Tom Brady rules
or something like that. You know,
if you just do that instead
of writing like, hey. Dot Dot,
dot and then in the email, be like,
what the fuck was with those calls?
You know what I mean? Oh, Bill, we get it.
And if you want to send an email
that could possibly be red, uh,
or who's kidding, who stumbled
upon by me, uh, please send it to
bill@themnpodcast.com.
Also if you'd like to follow the
Monday morning podcast on Twitter,
um, it's at the m m podcast.
Um, all right. And with that,
it's time for uh, my
attempts at reading out loud.
All right. Dollar Shave club,
everybody. Dollar Shave Club, you know,
lots of players will be sporting playoff
beards now that the post season is
here. Uh, leave that
to the pros. All right,
kick off your year the right
way with a fresh blade shave.
That's why millions of others have
joined dollar Shave club.com dollar shave
club knows the key to getting
an amazing shave is simple. One,
use a fresh dollar shave club blade to
use their doctorate copies. Easy shape.
Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing razors
right to your door for a third of the
price of those greedy
mega razor corporations.
That means listeners who switched now
can afford the luxury of shaving with a
fresh blade anytime and
save hundreds this year.
And when you combine that fresh
blade with their doctor cabbies,
easy shave butter, it just
glides. It's unimaginably smooth.
Just imagine the smoothest thing
ever and it's smoother than that.
You can't even imagine how
smooth it is. I'm telling you,
it's not your average safe foam. It
shave foam. It won't dry out your skin.
The all natural ingredients.
Leave your skin feeling soft,
smooth and moisturized after
every shave. Take it from me.
Use a fresh dollar shave club. Play
with Dr cabbies. Easy shave butter.
If you want the most gentle
shave imaginable. Dollar
Shave club.com/burt today,
join that@dollarshaveclub.com
slash burst. Sorry,
I went a little light
with the doctor copies.
I mean a hotel room right now and I
don't need anybody knocking at the two.
Um, 13 and nine. What's
going on here? The, uh,
Broncos a knocking on the
door here in the red zone. Uh,
who do you like ODL? Like, I think
the Steelers are gonna win this one.
I just do. I think, uh, I don't know why.
I just think that they're
going to win here. Uh,
of course you don't know why bill, you
barely watched any football this year.
Oh, by the way, congratulations
to the Alabama Crimson tide.
I can't believe I forgot to, uh, you
know, give them a shout out their fucking,
uh, Nick Saban Five,
count them five NCAA
football championships.
I mean, this guy's like beyond a
fucking legend. Beyond the legend.
Unbelievable game. Uh, congratulations
to clubs and forget their,
I hope you guys get back again. I
was rooting for Clemson. Of course.
Just cause it's fun to root against
Alabama. I don't really hate those guys.
It's just fun to root against
him cause you know who I,
I just don't like pile it on.
Anybody can just become a college
football fan and just root for the best
fucking team. I don't
want to do that right.
And a that fucking onside
kick call. Fucking tremendous.
What a call and the way that
they hit the whole thing though.
That was the game right there.
Unbelievable. So anyways, here we go.
Plowing ahead a me on
these. Oh Jesus. Oh Geez.
But I'll go put me on these, these
[inaudible] dry and your
balls in 2016. Boudou
[inaudible] grabbed my balls and see
what I mean, they're nice and dry.
Take that look off your
face. You'll like my balls,
no matter what the race put on me
undies and dry, I'll get tanked.
And they even make them for the ladies.
Oh yeah, they'll dry out. Fucking clam.
Even if you're in the mood. Um, be undies.
What's the secret to the
two New Year's resolutions?
Make the first step real easy. Uh,
like the first thing you do every day.
Put on underwear.
This year I with the old and with the
news step into a fresh new pair of me on
these,
the world's most comfortable underwear
and it's the easiest resolution you can
make. Head to on.com.
Choose from a variety of styles in limited
edition patterns for both men and the
fucking lady and they'll be
delivered right to your deal with me.
UNDIES is the next level of underwear.
You thought your deck was comfortable.
Now where do you take, where do you
take your balls to the next level?
Every pair is made with
their signature modal model.
Mill fabric proven to be
twice as soft as cotton.
Where, where did you
prove that at the x games.
Like all they say that like you can,
you can do research and
find that out anyways.
They don't just feel better
than regular undies. Um,
they make you feel invincible.
What are they under roofs
and you're eight years old.
Come on and it's guaranteed me the most
comfortable underwear you've ever worn
or your first pair is free.
So start your new years in.
Don't start your new years out with old
saggy underwear. Make a change Ed to me,
undies.com/bar right now and
get 20% off your first order.
If he know like your relationship and you
want to take back ground that you gave
away, the only way to do it is
to get brand new underwear. Okay.
Cause once you're
comfortable with somebody,
you walk around half an
a nude anyways, right?
And they're not going to
take you seriously if he
got holes in your underwear
with pubes sticking out, like some
sort of fucked up vegetable. All right,
that's disgusting. Um, anyways,
plus shipping is always free for
all the orders in us and Canada.
So for 20% off your first order of the
world's most comfortable underwear.
I had to be on these.com/burger right
now. And lastly, but not leastly. Uh,
all look at, they kept the horse
from the old a mile high stadium.
I went to a game there, I told you that
right? stamps.com one great resolution.
Sorry I'm watching TV here. One great
resolution you can make for the new year.
Maximize every minute and every
dollar of your small business.
I know an easy way to do
that. Actually I don't,
stamps.com is telling me about it.
Think about how much time you've wasted.
Go into the post office
driving there, finding parking,
not scoring any coke, right.
stamps.com is the better
way to get postage.
Just use what you already have,
your computer and your printer
to get official US postage. Um,
the fuck is Jim Simpson. Man just died.
He had a great run 89
years. Good for him. Um,
everything you would do it,
the post office you can do right from
your desk with just a fraction at just a
fraction of the cost of one of
those expensive postage meters.
I use stamps.com anytime
I'm selling posters,
I'm a moron if I can figure it out.
So can you, it's so convenient.
I can do it right for my home standing
in my brand new fucking me undies.
How you like that, Huh? Right now. Sorry.
This is like an advertising threesome
here right now or a twosome right now.
Sign up for stamps.com and use my
last name for, for this special offer,
four week trial plus $110 bonus offer.
That of course includes postage
and a digital scale. A don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before
you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top
of the homepage and type in Bar B, u.
R. R N. Mercifully. That's the end
of me reading out loud for this week.
Um,
here's a stat I had to look up
because Don Myra sent me a, uh,
a text. I tried to drop
names here. By the way,
I'm on his podcast this past week. Uh,
Don [inaudible] sent me a
text this morning. He goes,
how many quarterbacks have
you ever seen in the NFL?
Yeah.
Have a hail Mary pass, throw a
successful, hey ma, hail Mary.
Pass once in their career.
Forget about twice in
the same season. And uh,
I had to go look it up. I was like,
I gotta I gotta find this out, man.
I gotta find out a, you know,
if anybody's ever done it,
cause I was like, there's
no way anybody's done it.
In my lifetime of watching the last 30
something years of watching football,
holy fuck. I've been watching
football for 38 years. Oh my God.
I'm old. I started watching
it religiously in about 1978.
Um, yeah, about that 78, 79.
Jesus fucking Christ. Um, put it this way.
The first Superbowl I watched was
super bowl 12, and they're at 50,
so there you go. Wow, this
is going to be my, uh,
well would that be my 50,
not 51st fucking idiot.
My 39th Superbowl 50 minus
12. Plus I watched 12, right?
Yeah. So that day. There you go. Yeah,
there's a lot of people right now
actually think I'm wrong, but it's true.
It's my 39th I'm going to be watching
anyways. Let's plow ahead here. Um,
so I looked it up. Successful
Hail Mary's. Okay. Um,
there's only one guy that I saw since
they started keeping the stat in 1975,
at least on Wikipedia. I didn't go to
the football reference.com which I love.
Um,
the one guy who's ever done done it
twice since they kept the stats in 1975,
Steve Bart Koski,
Steve Bar Koski and there's no way to
picture Steve Art Koski and not have the
song, this song go through your head
walking on air. I never
thought I could be so free.
He throwing the ball to Bailey.
Watch you Johnson and
to another guy. Yeah.
He looked like the greatest American hero.
He did it in 1978 against the saints.
And then he did it again in 1983
against the 40 niners in the, uh,
NFC west, which back
then was only four teams.
It was the Los Angeles Rams,
the New Orleans saints,
the Atlanta Falcons, and
the San Francisco 49ers.
The quarterbacks are Steve
Bart Koski, a 78 seat bar.
Koski Archie Manning,
and I think they had a quarterback
controversy. Pat Hayden,
Vince Ferragamo back and forth, uh,
four Vince cover gum. I tried to take the
money and went to the fucking CFL. Oh,
Jewish. Never saw him again. And uh,
it would be Steve de
or Jim Plunkett at 78.
I did this with fucking
Joe Bart. Nick, one time.
We tried to name all the
starting quarterbacks in the
NFL in 1978 we went around
the league. So I think it
was a FCEs was Burt Jones,
Bob Greasy, Steve Grogan,
Richard Todd and Joe
Ferguson for the bills.
That was Terry Bradshaw.
Dan, pastor Rainey,
who the fuck was quarterback for the
browns? It was either Mike Phipps or,
uh, Brian's site.
And then the Bengals was Kenny
Anderson. Kenny The candle
as Colin's were sent.
They Call Him Kenny the candle
Coz one blow and he was out.
You ever see that one on NFL films?
And they cut the kitty and I said,
he's like, I'll fuck Colin's worth.
Um, and let's see, was Craig Morton?
I'll just do the AFC cause I know this
is fucking driving everybody nuts but,
or this is my f I have to do it
now. Cause now it's in my head.
Craig Morton was at the orange
crush Broncos. Ken Stabler,
Kenny Snake Stabler for the,
uh, the Raiders. Dan Fouts,
the Great Dan Fouts air
Corey l with the address.
Jim Zorn was Seattle and then a fuck.
There's always one that gets me.
Who the fuck was with the chiefs?
It was before black ledge
was after Len Dawson.
Who the fuck was the quarterback?
There's a good one for you.
There's some poor bastard in
Kansas City right now screaming at
who the fuck was it? I even know, I
think like the Buccaneers had Gary hough.
Lynn Dickey was out in Greenbay.
Jim Hart was, how the fuck do I
remember those? I remember Kansas City,
Kansas City. I gotta look this up.
Kansas City chief quarterback. Hey,
it's going to get better guys.
I played drums this week out and I played
with the Colin Hay for men at work.
All right, I'm going to tell
her story in a second here.
Just fucking deal with this
here. Kansas City chiefs,
QB 1970 why do I care?
Why do I fucking care? Lists of
Kansas City chief quarterbacks.
This is fucking made for me.
Who's the last person who fucking went
to this starting quarterback season to
season.
Okay.
Jesus. They've had some guys. Yeah.
Joe Montana. Warren Moon, rich Gannon.
All right, here we go. Here we
go. Back at it, out back in it up
1970 I'd never get this. Mike
Livingston and Tony Adams,
this is the one that
always fucking gets me.
Leonie Dawson left in 1975 and
then Mike Livingston took over.
You know there was a guy who played for
the Bengals that Bill Walsh was talking
about. He only played for one
season. He got fucking injured.
And Bill Walsh to this day still said
he's the greatest quarterback that he ever
coached, but he's probably still
trying to motivate or he was, anyways,
she passed away, probably still trying
to motivate fucking Montana or a young,
even after they retired,
get them to rake the leaves
better that day or some shit. Um,
I can't remember the guy's fucking name,
but that's one to look up. Uh, anyways,
so yeah, this,
this week I did a Greg
Baron show at Largo and uh,
I was one of those things too. It's
not quite like the goddamn comedy jam.
This was one where they
actually have people, uh,
for the most part it's musicians
coming out and telling funny stories.
And this is something that Greg
did a number of years ago and uh,
he's brought the show
back. And, um, so anyways,
let me, let me get the line up
here so I don't fuck this up.
I did take a picture of it. I'm so
fucking disorganized. I apologize. Um,
all right. So it was
calling, hey, Tom Morello,
myself and Chris Fairbank's and other
comedians, those two comedians. And then,
uh, two musicians. And I got to a,
okay,
I got to play a with the
band, told some stories,
and I got to play with the band.
And then afterwards I got to play
with Collin a and we played, uh,
who can it be now, which was,
uh, just beyond a fucking thrill.
And he was the nicest fucking guy,
so generous to let me play. Um,
and he had this really cool way that
he wanted to bring me out. He goes, uh,
he just went out there. He was telling
stories, he was fucking hilarious.
And then he just randomly goes, you know,
and I had the weirdest dream last
night. I was dreaming. I was, you know,
playing a show. And, uh,
I was playing, you know,
who could it be now? And the crowd
collapsed because it's such a huge hit.
And he goes, the weirdest thing, you
know, it built burrow was on drums, like,
you know, and I just waited a second.
Then I just walked out and sat down.
Everybody started laughing and
then he told this great story.
I'm not going to repeat the
story. Just I, it's his story.
So I'm sure if he wants to
tell it on a podcast, he can,
but he tells his fucking hilarious
story that ends with the word cunt.
And he told me after I say cunt,
basically you do the drum fill intro
and then we'll go into the song and uh,
let me play it anyway, you know,
went off, went off pretty good man.
And actually, uh, I don't
know. It's fucking unreal, man.
I played like 20 years by myself in a
rehearsal space until it finally dawned on
me that I'm supposed to be out
interacting with other fucking people.
So now that I've kind of opened
Pandora's box, I just, I told you,
I made this rule that I'm
not gonna ask to sit in,
but if somebody asked me to play,
I'm gonna fucking play. All right.
That includes if I can be a town
and if I'm drinking in a bar,
if I go out to a bar and
your local band is played,
if you come up to me and asked
me to sit in with your band,
I'm going to fucking do it. All
right. I know. And this is a warning.
It's a warning. I'm gonna do it and
I'm gonna fuck up. So, you know,
if you want a story, I'll fucking
do it. Cause it's fun as hell to me.
And it's weird. I don't feel
any pressure whatsoever because
I'm a comedian. Well, what's the pressure?
He's going to sit down and play drums.
He's going to stick. Of course he is.
Everybody already knows
it, so it's fine. Um,
plus everybody has looks at the singer
anyways, but it's a, it's a lot of fun.
And I've been, uh, getting
psycho back into lessons and, um,
I told you I've been taking, um,
I've been taking some lessons. Um,
you remember a long time ago when I
watched that Mars Volta Video and uh,
I was talking about their drummer,
who's Dave [inaudible] at the
time I was going, Holy Fuck,
look at this guy's fucking unbelievable,
blah, blah blah. Well, from doing that,
he must've heard the clip. He reached
out to me on Twitter and Lo and behold,
he lives in La.
And every once in a while I go by and
I take a lesson with the guy and uh,
he's a fucking unbelievable teacher and
he's been teaching me techniques. So my,
you know, I'm one of those guys, I
grabbed the drumsticks the same way.
Like a toddler would, would
just my fit meaty fucking fist,
just right over both of them and it was
causing my arms to be doing all the work
and my forum, if ain't
drummers are listening to this,
if you have like that fucking, you know,
that pain in your forums and
all that, you know, that's,
I was kind of going through that shit and
he is teaching me this technique where
you let the stick do the work and it's
holding it in this particular way that
does not seem fucking natural at all.
And uh, it has been a motherfucker
but you know, incrementally I've been,
it's gradually working its
way into my playing and uh,
it's been, it's totally been worth it.
And we've been going this jazz
book and I'm like most students,
like I work on something for three
seconds and then want to go onto the next
thing so I can have that
sense of accomplishment and
just get through a whole
fucking page and a, and I was moving
ahead and every time I'd go to the lesson,
I would still not have
the first thing down.
And I've been taking lessons, you know,
on and off since the summer. I mean,
I get busy and I can't go for like
a month or something, but, um,
I'm still on that first page and it
finally dawned on me in the past week to,
to be like, dude, just work on this one
fucking thing and fuck everything else.
And I just sorta sat down 15 minutes
a day just working on this thing.
Um, you know,
make it a little bit of an improvement
and then being fuck having to start over
and blah, blah, blah, blah
and all that shit. And um,
I actually had a great lesson this week
where I think he actually was saying
that I was just, I was
finally starting to improve,
which made my fucking
weak. So anyways, um,
I don't know what the fuck I'm going with
this. I'm rambling all over the place.
What are we up to here? 45
minutes. Jesus Christ. Bill,
can we fucking get on with
this here? Um, oh, by the way,
somebody told me to watch
a show, top boy, TLP,
boy on Netflix and a, I want a
Netflix for the life of, I can,
I can figure out how to search
when I'm on the Internet.
I can't fucking do it when
I'm on the TV. I don't,
how do you search when you're
on the TV, if anybody knows,
I would really appreciate it.
But anyways, I'm going to be, um,
I'm going to be, uh, playing
out again this week. Uh,
I'm doing that Bonzo bash thing.
I'm hosting the Bonzo bash co-hosting
and I don't even know who I'm hosting
with.
It's going to be an Anaheim this Friday
night and I'm a Brian tissues wonderful
event or all these drummers that I
grew up watching sit down and play led
Zeppelin songs,
which is going to be the shit I'm
going to get to host it and uh,
with somebody else, it's going
to be fucking awesome. So,
and I will be sitting in
for one song, once again,
risking total humiliation,
which, you know,
I'll probably make an ass of myself who
gives a fuck. Right. Um, but anyways,
uh, oh, I know what I
wanted to talk about.
Fuck. In the Arizona cardinals packers
game, I started to talk about it and uh,
you know, you would think last week
after watching that dude on the Bengals,
intercept the ball and then fucking
walk into the locker room like, well,
I guess that's that, right?
You'd think that these, these damn
kids today they'd learned something.
Patrick Peterson, who I
fucking love LSU Kid, right?
Incomplete fourth down.
That ought to fucking do it.
Two and a half minutes left.
This guy's walking down the sideline
waving to the crowd, doing editing.
Damn near blowing kisses to
the crowd. Like it's over.
What he's playing pack is in Aaron
fucking Roger's fucking hilarious.
Two and a half minutes of football left
and he's walking around doing that and
what happened?
Two minutes and 25 football seconds
later he gets beat on a jump ball in the
fucking end zone on a hail Mary
to send it into overtime. Um,
fucking unbelievable. How many times
does somebody gonna fucking do that?
How many times are you going to run
down the field? You got the football,
you're not past the goal line.
You already start holding it out.
And Don baby slaps it out of your hand.
Are you fucking, you know, you have,
you spike it over the,
you know, over your back.
You know that one we had throw it
down over your shoulder and you,
you get big toes across the
end zone, but the ball is,
and how many fucking times you're
going to see people do that.
I just don't understand why. I know. Get
it. So anyways, let's plow ahead here.
Uh, all right, here's some of the
questions. Are the letters for this week.
All right. Pasta Bill. If you
want to get good at making pasta,
of course I do begin with a Janero
cantala those videos on food tube.
All right. I don't know if I
said, I'm probably just say right.
It's g e n a R R o.
And then the last name is C.
O. N. T. A. L. D. O. S. No, d.
O. Apostrophe s can tall dose. Uh,
the guy taught me so much I even
wished him a happy birthday. Uh,
also pay attention to sorts of flour
you're using cheers to you and your
Mondays. Yeah. What's going
on? Some people use flowers,
some people use that semolina
some people use a mixture of both.
I tell you, I like doing it. I think
it goes back to when I was a kid,
I was one of those kids like playing
in mud puddles, you know what I mean?
So it was a, there's just
something about that.
I think that's why like, I like making
like, like pie crust and shit like that.
It's just a big gooey
fucking mess. It's fun. Um,
but I'll definitely, uh, I'll check
that out if I can get online here.
All right. Cooking Asian food.
Okay.
All right, Bill, how are you? You
freckled cont Jesus. Jesus. No,
happy new year. I'm huge
fan from Belgium here.
Nice Bedlam and Belgium. ACDC
flick of the switch elbow.
How many fucking balls are
you gonna drop on Peyton here?
This could be his last game ever.
What are you doing? Jesus Christ.
And when did shoulder pads
get so small? Let me see.
Shoulder pads on people and the
fucking, the shoulder pads was so big.
The shirt didn't even cover your belly.
You still run around with
half shirts on. By the way,
can grump pull his pants up or
get a longer fucking jersey?
You started to look like
a waitress at Hooters.
Alright. A huge fan from Belgium here. Um,
I'm sure saying he showed his midriff.
There's probably the Ron Ron reference.
Who knows, you know the little
ass country that people know, uh,
about because of Austin Powers. Oh,
I thought I knew them from a, I
thought isn't, that's not Brussels.
The muscles from Brussels.
That was the guy who used to,
who's the guy used to do the
splits now fuck is the guy's name.
He wasn't, I must break you.
He wasn't Steven Seagal was the other
guy from blood splat gives a fuck.
Belgium. Yeah. Luxembourg
and Belgium. Right,
right there a tucked in there. Right.
They're a battle of the bulge right there.
And then France and Germany.
My nuts in between a Amsterdam in the
fucking Denmark there Copenhagen you get
tucked right there staring at the
fucking a bad teeth of that. The English,
aren't you looking across the
channel? Maybe not enough.
Maybe if I had a map I could find
it. Yeah. All right. Love Deaf.
This F is for family. Please come to
our f our freckle of a country. Uh,
dude, I'm definitely gonna go there.
I'm definitely going to go there
without a fucking doubt. I'm a,
and we're waiting to hear about the
second season for F is for family.
The pitch went fucking great. Uh,
when out of there we were all excited.
I got a great feeling about it and I'm
gonna let you guys know as soon as I find
out. Um, okay. But I got a
good feeling about it. So,
uh, and I'm definitely
gonna do a European tour.
I did Australia and Asia last
year, so this time it's time.
We had the other way.
I'm going to do a Europe this time and I
want to hit all the countries I've been
to. I'd like to add a few more.
And I also want to do a little
bit of eastern Europe, but, uh,
if we do get a second season, I don't
know how many episodes that would be,
I'd think it'd be at least
10. And then, you know,
we gotta sit down and write them and, uh,
we want to make it as good as the first
season, you know, and even better,
which of course we do, it's
going to take a lot of time.
So I gotta kind of
figure out, you know, uh,
once they gave us the Yay or nay on
that. But like I said, I got a really,
really, really positive vibes,
a lot of laughs in the room and um,
which is always good. So anyways,
he said the guy says, anyway,
I've heard you talking about
cooking more Asian food. Oh wait,
this is a different one. Um, oh,
it's the same guy. Sorry. And He,
this is the same guy from
Belgium because anyways,
I've heard you talking about wanting
to cook more Asian food on your podcast
since I love cooking as well.
Please allow me to recommend you.
Some Korean cuisine has a
lot of spicy food. Oh yeah.
Kimchi and all that stuff. Um,
okay.
Yeah, I've, I've been to those
Korean barbecue and all that stuff.
I love all of that stuff, but it's
just so different from the stuff here.
I'm really intimidated about cooking it,
uh, which is so stupid, you
know, if I'm, I'm afraid of it,
I should just just sit down and be like,
okay, let's start with something easy.
How do you make the sticky rice? You know,
if you could just make sticky rice
alone, that's the shit, right?
That's the best fucking rice there is.
I don't want to hear everybody
tell me it's not fucking healthy.
I don't give a fuck. You
know, it's fucking delicious.
Um, Korean cuisine has
a lot of spicy food,
which is great for losing weight since
you tend to be full more quickly and
drink more water, plus a lot of other
health benefits. If you are interested,
please check out. Uh, I can't,
it's m a n, G, C, h, I on Youtube. Oh,
I've got to do this. Uh, I guess
I go, I guess this is a lady, a,
she's a Korean housewife who
is funny as hell and learns,
uh, teaches you, you said learns
you how to cook. It's teaches,
teaches you how to cook great
traditional and overall easy recipes.
Now you've got to teach me some Belgian
words. I gave you one there. Huh?
A recommendations are a Belgium words.
Belgium. A Rep recommendations
are spicy pork stir fry.
Jane Sing Chicken. I
didn't want to say it's j.
A J a m e o n. G. Judge. Ami Young.
That sounds like an annoying
character in fucking star wars,
which is black bean sauce noodles.
Some other shit that I can't say Korean
barbecue, which I bet you've had before.
Yeah, I have. What is that?
The hacky American thing? Well,
I've had Korean food. I
went to Korea Barbecue.
I literally just said that
Japanese cuisine is mostly salty,
sweet and Umami. What does
Umami mean? Is that Oh,
Mommy Burger. Better that flavors.
Lots of vegetables. No butter.
Soy Sauce, which is amazing for you
and rich and enrich taste. Yeah.
I got to tell you mad people,
when I went over to Asia, man,
they will fucking in shape. People
are just in shape over there,
you know?
I bet if you fat in Asia, they've just
been looking at rich motherfucker.
He must be traveling. He's got enough
money to get to an apple piece.
I'm fucking, I uh, I'm too tired.
I didn't want to say Applebee's.
Applebee's is not a fattening places. It,
what's a good fat cheese? They'll
just wrap up the podcast. Okay.
If I'm going to be this off right now,
what the fuck's going to happen when I
go to do my shows tonight? All right.
Now, Chinese food, I don't
know a lot about, uh,
cool to know is that Chinese food in the
states and Europe is not actual Chinese
food. No, it isn't. That's
their surreptitious way of
trying to fucking kill us.
That's what they're trying to do.
They know we have the bomb, right?
They think that China is attacking
us on two levels right now,
giving us food that's going to give us
a heart attack and they're going to fuck
with our economy somehow. Somehow.
We're tied in with them and they're
going to pull the fucking rug up anyways.
He said modified for our taste buds,
but I'm guessing they have amazing
stuff too. Yeah, I would think so.
I would think so.
Um,
no. Fuck. Am I getting
the hiccups here? Uh,
Thai in Vietnamese food is mostly
spring rolls. Jesus Christ, you go, oh,
we'll do the whole continent here.
Um,
let me get some water. Oh,
fuck. Completely. Mr. Glass.
Okay. Fucking bad angle here. Um, lastly,
okay. Know Thai, Vietnamese,
mostly spring rolls. Spicy Curry.
I love our guy from fucking Belgium is
telling me about Asian food or you at
least Asian, lots of coriander,
which I personally detest because
it tasted of dishwasher product,
dishwasher, product. Lastly, if
you really want to go hardcore,
try out North Korean food, it's
basically starving yourself.
You'll be able to see your ginger pube
ding down without a mirror again and no
time. Pretty Edgy, Huh? Yes.
You're making fun of the fact that they're
under a dictator that doesn't feed a
very edgy, very edgy. Uh,
hope this helped go fuck yourself.
Lots of love for Nia. You know, Cleo,
um, oh shit. I guess
I'll give that, you know,
I love how Asia stops with
people that we can, you know,
it doesn't go into India. That's also
Asia, right? Isn't the Middle East,
isn't that also Asia? Russia,
you know. Anyway, so like that
can fucking Forrest Gump. Alright.
Hey Billy Beane, uh, Ben,
a fan of the podcast for
a while now. Yada Yada.
I need some advice or just a fresh
perspective on what to do. I'm 23.
Uh, yeah, the primary life dropped out
of high school. Like a dip shit at 17.
Got My GED when I was 19.
I, you're back in the game.
You're back in the game and it decided
to start becoming a productive member of
society. Everything was
going good. Paycheck meant a,
the dating pool opened up, tried a
few jobs, et cetera. But now I'm 23.
I quit my job to go to, to
go to school for advertising.
Slash art at an artsy college.
Should probably mention the only
thing I'm truly good at is art.
Mainly pen and ink stuff. Well, dude,
that's a great thing and he can make
a ton of fucking money doing that.
It's just that schools generally
speaking are not geared towards that.
Um, so yeah,
you will fucking bored and then you
took shit that you weren't good at,
made you feel like an asshole. You fucking
dropout your party for a few years.
Right. Bagged a couple of who is
and now you're coming back, dude.
You fine. You're 23, dude, you're
fine. Uh, that was eight months ago.
I missed the sign. I
missed the sign up date.
It just lacked the general knowledge
slash support on going about it.
I spent six months grinding
the living shit out of drawing,
trying to achieve something I might be
able to take some pride in. Didn't work.
I was just going to say, you're being
too hard on yourself. Your next line is,
I'm hard on myself to the point where
I'm thinking I'll never be handed a metal
is the greatest that ever
fucking lives. So why bother?
Yeah.
Ah, Jesus Dude. Well listen,
Richard Pryor's the greatest of all time
and I'll never come close to that guy.
That does not going to stop me. You
just try to see how close you can come.
Some people you can't pass and
that's all right. You know,
you just try to come as close to him.
Try to just like try to go as high up
the all time ladder as you possibly can
and who knows? If you
keep pushing yourself,
okay,
listen, you
okay?
You don't know what your limits are until
you keep fucking throwing yourself out
there. Especially if you're hard on
yourself. You probably be in way.
You're way better than you think you
are. You're going to be fine. All right,
you're depressing me here anyways.
I've since quit drawing and now do nothing
but troll around dating sites all day
and hooking up with
semi-decent looking women,
women as a way to stay positive
and cure boredom. I'm not lazy.
I've done primarily a
manual labor jobs and no,
I have the back for it, but Jesus Christ,
I can't force myself to pull the trigger
on anything because I can't be the top
of the crop or the very God damn
best. I want people fulfilled.
I've been standing at a crossroad,
my Dick and my head for nearly a year
and he sort of vice be fucking amazing.
Don't hold back. If you think I need to
be ripped a new one, I can handle it.
Thanks. Go Fuck Yourself. Yeah Dude,
you've got yourself into a completely
paralyzed state here because it's like you
gotta you just bought a guitar and
because you're not Jimi Hendrix,
within the first two weeks you're
going to fucking quit. All right.
If Jimmy Hendricks did that, he
wouldn't be Jimmy Hendrix. All right?
Okay.
All right. Either look just if you,
whatever you like to do in life, just go
out and do it all right. And enjoy it.
And don't put that level
of pressure on yourself.
Like what was your dad like?
The Great Santini is something,
I'm trying to figure out why
you like this, but like, um,
the reason why he can't pull the trigger
on anything else in life is because you
actually have a strong cause.
I think you have a strong sense on what
makes you happy and what you want to do.
Alright.
And you know that despite the fact that
you're being totally negative about your
drawing,
you know that that's what you want to
do and you have such a passion for it,
that you're that hard on yourself.
And then also it's preventing you from
getting a job at the fucking Costco or
wherever the goddamn place you're
going to end up fucking working at. Um,
I would, I don't know if I was
you, I would continue drawing.
I get into computers and all that.
There's all kinds of stuff I've seen
people do drugs on computers and they
turned that into building websites,
which helps to pay for their,
their studio and the shit that
they really want to do this,
there's tons of money to
make in the arts. Don't,
don't let anybody ever fucking tell you
that there isn't just you just helping
people make it in show business.
Yeah.
Alright. This p people who get head
shots give acting classes and all that,
just doing that shit. People
make a small fucking fortune.
So if you're actually a talented
artists, you can actually,
you're going to be fine. Um,
you just have to stop beating the shit
out of yourself. All right? So, uh,
just pay attention to that voice in your
head and when it tells you you can't do
something, just tell it to
shut the fuck up basically.
Even if you have to say
it out loud, you know,
just make sure you're not looking at
somebody you care about as they're telling
you a story. When you think of those
thoughts, just, you know, maybe,
maybe say it in your brain
first. All right? Okay. Advice.
No one to relate to cheeses. He's a
fucking gloomy this week. All right.
Advice. No one to relate to
causing loading loneliness.
Okay.
All right. Hey, Billy, bets. Love the
podcasts. You stand up after a family.
They all put a smile on my face.
Well, that's great. Okay. Um,
I'm sensing that all of a sudden
now the smile is going to go away.
I hope you read this because he had
it. Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah.
My problem is I have no one to relate
to and I fear I might as well read this
here. I hope you read this because
I've been doing everything positive,
but I just can't seem to get
my life where I want it to be.
It's a bit of a long road, so
please bear with me. Oh fuck this.
It's a long email. Did you
know I can't read out loud.
All right.
My problem is I have no one to relate
to and I fear I might be caught.
This might be causing
me to be lonely in life.
I fear that if I continue the way
I'm going, I may never get over it.
I'm in my last semester of college in
an engineering program and I've made
almost no friends throughout
my entire stay at college.
I am at the top of my classes and I'm
lining up jobs at big tech companies.
Now you're probably managing some
point Dexter with the pocket or pocket
protector and all that.
Actually I was, that's exactly,
that was the picture you were painting,
sir. Uh, quite the opposite actually.
I've been working out for a few years
now and I have one and I am one of the
jacked people in my classes. All right,
so now I'm picture is that
dude in American psycho,
highly achieving, totally shredded,
cannot relate to human beings.
Um, I dress well, eat healthy. Please
tell me you don't listen to Huey. Uh,
Huey Lewis and the news. Um,
yeah,
and always make sure to keep myself clean.
I feel like I might alienate my
classmates from interacting with me.
They probably think I'm just a jock
in their class where it's quite the
opposite. I'm into gaming,
chess and all of that. Dude,
you're like a fucking
a renaissance man here.
So I figure I might try to
interact with the opposite crowd,
the Non Geeky people.
I know a way to meet people is to
get out there and do something. I,
I like doing, playing some sport
or joining a club or volunteering.
The problem is with my
program and my work,
I have little time to be doing much else.
The free time I have is Friday or Saturday
nights that I spend by myself playing
video games or playing guitar
because I have nothing else to do.
While you could go out those nights,
all right. It wasn't always this way.
This is like a movie.
When I was in high school,
my life was completely the opposite.
I didn't work out, eat healthy,
work hard or nothing. But I always
find ways to make new friends,
make people laugh and start conversations.
Now that I'm doing everything right,
it seems my only problem is
social out. Jesus Christ. Dude.
So you know what you're
doing. You just too busy.
I figured once I Graduate College,
things will only get worse.
I lost all of my faith, my family,
apart from my older brother
who was in another country.
So once I graduate college,
I'll truly be alone.
No one to grab a beer with no one to help
me move or anything to help me move or
anything. Despite all this,
I try to be positive and thankful what
I have and what I have accomplished.
Sorry for the long email and go fuck
yourself. Yeah, Dude. You just look.
You already know how to make friends. I
would. You need to make time to do it.
I'm playing video games by
yourself is very antisocial.
Uh, playing guitars.
Always. Cool. That's fun.
Why don't you play guitar
with somebody else?
Find somebody who plays drums and play
bass. Get together, do some covers.
Okay.
You know, jam, fuck around,
you know, drink some beers,
invite some ladies over. And he did
every week he just adds some more shit.
Right. You know, start taking bets,
open your own fucking a draft kinks,
you know, maybe start selling coke.
Just keep expanding your
ring of a social interaction.
I'm obviously fucking with
you, but no, I would, uh,
there's a bunch of people
that are into video games.
Why don't you find somebody
that you can play against?
Can you do that anymore to kids do that?
Or do you have to go online to do it?
You know,
is that like Courtney now does two
people not sit next to each other with an
Atari with the joystick and the one
red button is, are we past that?
I don't fucking know, but it seems
like you know how to do that stuff.
He just got busy and uh, with all your
achievements, you, you know, sometimes,
you know, when you go after a
goal, some things suffer. Alright.
I've talked about this numerous
times when I was on, um,
you know, when I was 36 years old, I was,
I was fucking living alone in a studio
apartment that they call the one bedroom,
sleeping on a futon. I remember
days just going by going,
what the fuck have I done?
The only thing I've worked on
is trying to become a comedian.
Everything else is at the
starting line. And uh,
over the next 10 years I just
worked on some shit like that.
So that's all you need to
do. All right. Jesus Christ.
I'm starting to feel like doctor Phil
here. Um, all right, what do we got here?
Third and goal?
Broncos have the ball with three minutes
left and I'm doing a fucking podcast.
Touchdown Broncos. All right. All right.
Broncos ne go celebrate and act like
a bunch of fucking idiots when Ben
Roethlisberger has three minutes
left. This one is not over. All right,
so what does this do?
This puts them up by five.
Hey people in the crowd
holding up two fingers,
like the crowd is going to look at them.
Oh yeah. Yeah. We should go for too.
Should we, we shouldn't just be
up by six. Thank you. Thank you.
You in the fucking a
mezzanine level. Ah, fuck.
But we're going to have to go to
Denver. Is this going to be one more?
One more Bray that, either way. This
is going to be great. Either this,
you get to see Brady versus a
Peyton manning. One more time.
I'm assuming he's retiring,
which is stupid. Or you get
to see another patriots,
a Steelers match up with fucking Big Ben.
Big Bad. Not Afraid of anything. Big
Bed. Both great teams. All right.
That's the podcast for this week.
I apologize that my head was
kind of all over the place.
I don't know what flying and going
to the fucking airport does to me.
Um,
but uh, it makes me even more
fucking scatterbrain. So anyways,
go fuck yourselves and I will talk
to you on Thursday. Okay. All right.